chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year
seasonal Classic Events are back the
summer chess classic August 2nd and the
winter chess classic wraps up the year
in December September brings back
everyone's favorite chess night Alex
where some of the world's best don't
even know what's coming and compete for
a 150 000 prize fund in partnership with
U.S chess the best in the U.S fight to
be the nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
[Music]